- Y'all booked a movie theater
to like see the Era's Tour?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Yeah, we had to.
We've been at a concert,
I've been, I went a little too
many times. (Kelly laughing)
But it was just a fun thing
to get to do with our friends.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- Have us all together, so.
- Oh no, it did look fun.
I wanna show this B-roll.
So this is video of the
screening that you had.
- [Taylor] Oh no.
- [Kelly] Wait, up, there.
- There he is.
- Okay, wait.
(audience cheering)
Can I tell you, can I
tell you my favorite part?
My favorite part isn't even the flip.
- Okay.
- My favorite part is
the drag of the hand.
It's like, it is like,
did you just see that?
Like, like do you, does he do that often?
Do you back flip often?
- What the flip or the drag of the hand?
- [Kelly] Yeah, the drag of the hand.
- He does, I mean, not like super often.
Not as often as he used to.
But he does flips-
- [Kelly] Trying to impress you.
- Our friends just like egg him on,
they're forever doing something.
They're like, "Do the
flip," and it happens.
- I say do it for as long as you can.
- [Taylor] I know, I'm trying to milk it.
- 'Cause once you hit 40, things change.
Yeah.
- Yeah, it feels differently today.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I paid for it the next day.
- [Kelly] Enjoy the flip.
- It was rough after that evening.
- Yeah, you have to
have like liquid courage
or something like it.
(Taylor laughing) Okay, so I have to ask
about something else that Taylor posted.
So which one we'll figure out.
But here, this is amazing.
So this is a bath night
for one of you, right?
This is a-
- [Taylor] Oh, boy.
- [Kelly] This is a bath night for you.
- [Taylor] Where are you
guys getting this stuff?
- [Kelly] No, yeah.
- [Taylor 2] Beautiful.
- So do you usually bath, do you usually,
are you into bubbles?
- I'm not the biggest. She loves bath.
- [Kelly] 'Cause they're wonderful.
- Yes, I would agree.
- I have a little problem with them.
- It looks like you enjoy them.
(audience laughing)
- I was in, okay, it took me
40 minutes to set up that bath.
I was in it for three
minutes and I got hot.
- [Kelly] Oh, you got-
- And then I'm out of it and I'm like,
this is a lot of work for like
three minutes in the bath.
I used too many bubbles.
So I was like, what do I do with them?
I made a hat, but yeah.
- All right, all right.
Let's say you're not into it, I got it.